tell me about this mixtape of hate that
you've made
so what started happening is as you get
bigger as you get more successful
you open the door for people to critique
everything you do and most of the people
who are critiquing you
usually aren't Where You Are
and all their critiquing comes from
people who are really at a low level of
life which is sad but what we do
people who are on the upper level
hearing the haters at lower level
like I said you'll never meet a hater
doing better than you
true statement
I started having fun with it
so I'll go through the comments While
most people don't go through comments
I go through them intentionally look for
the bad ones
and why I'll block and delete you
because the people on my page don't need
that negative energy
I'll block and delete you but I take a
snapshot
on my phone and I put it in the archive
so what happens is there's days where
I'm like you know what I really don't
want to do this today
I'm like oh hang on
so I started making these mixtapes with
all of these hate messages
about people talking [ __ ]
and it became such a source of fuel that
it was amazing because I know why you
hate me you hate me because you're
probably in the bed right now you're
probably an underachiever you're
probably somebody who doesn't want to do
anything with your life
so I make you question everything about
yourself so I'm going to continue making
you question yourself
by coming out here and being even more
successful So I listened to that where I
run I sometimes played in the house
and it sometimes gets on Jennifer's
nerves because I'm sitting there
listening to somebody talk match
on a loop about me and she's like why do
you do this [ __ ]
it's half comical
and it's half um it's half inspiring I'm
actually inspired by it I've heard you
say previously that listening to music
while you train is cheating so what
you're telling me is that the Silence of
your own dark thoughts isn't enough of a
soundtrack and you've had to crowd
Source insults from the internet
self-narrate it yep and then play it to
yourself while you train that's it I do
that sometimes yes yes have you got your
phone on you right now I want to hear it
no I I don't travel with my phone oh
yeah my phone does not go with me
anywhere why is that
once again man like right now I'm with
you
a lot of times people are in
conversations or they're somewhere
they're elsewhere you may think they're
with you but they're not
that phone is the biggest distraction in
the world
with the time so when it comes time for
the phone I'm on the phone we're not I
don't use it I'm all about being present
where I'm at so that's why that phone
right now no we do have it it's in your
it's silenced it's off so I do have my
phone right now but but usually I don't
take anywhere I go got you so while
you're listening to the
self-narrated insults of random people
on the internet that you don't like
right what are you thinking of while
you're listening to that while you're
working out or while you're walking
around the house
how'd that back in the day when I was
sometimes getting bullied or in a dark
place uh sometimes that would have
bothered me
how I would want to
clap back I I would want to be on there
all day explaining myself to people and
how now I'm in a place now where I can
hear it
and I can actually enjoy it I can
actually know where it's coming from
I've studied it so I don't just like
listen to it and like make fun of it I
actually study it because I was once
that negative person I was once that
person who saw someone successful
and didn't see how can I get there
I was like oh
yeah they're probably cheating or
they're probably doing this I was I was
that negative person because I wasn't
there and I didn't want to work to get
there
so these people who hate on people I've
studied them
and I've gained a lot of Knowledge from
them because I gained a lot of knowledge
for myself when I was in that dark place
so it's almost like reflecting an older
version of you back to yourself 100 I
had this idea
um uh called the reverse role model so
in a lot of places people might grow up
and not have good Role Models around
them you know like it would be great if
I had someone that was my hero that
could tell me how to be x uh good in
school well with work fantastic in
relationships whatever it might be
and a lot of people don't grow up with
that right and what I realized was
because that was me in in part from
where I was from but I realized there
was a lot of people that I got to see
that were like the sort of person I
didn't want to be like right and that
was the reverse role model so I could
look around I could say I really don't
want his relationship with his wife and
I hate the way that he is using alcohol
to get over the problems in his life he
doesn't have any Integrity or tell the
truth she is a liar and a backstabber
and a gossip
and the thing is that you can actually
achieve a lot of success in life by
avoiding failure like most success in
life actually is avoiding failure yes
you need to be able to be competent But
first you need to not get out of the
race that's the one second decision
right you need to not lose before you
can win right and the reverse role model
is you weaving your way through a
selection of people that you don't want
to be like and I think that you can get
an awfully long way just by doing that I
did that my entire life I had the
ultimate blueprint by watching my family
I was the youngest kid
so the youngest kid has the total
advantage
you know you may get picked on you may
get bullied with everybody but you sit
back and exactly what you said I sat
back and watched my dad definitely don't
want to do that
my mom my brother whoever it may be
I sat back and I paid attention to
everything around me and it was the
ultimate blueprint to how to live life
how not to live life how not to live
life is I watched people do [ __ ] I said
uh
I don't want to be like that
I like what you said about how
the criticism that you see from people
is coming from a very unique place
I think if you got to see the inner
texture of the people who don't like use
existence you'd feel more pity than
anger for the most part I think you'd
pity them yes
um and that's a realization that's taken
a long time
for me to to come up with because
everybody else feels or to me always
seems like everyone else has got it
together because I get to see only what
you choose to say only what I'm around
you doing that I get to see whereas I
get to observe my own
inefficiency and foibles 10 000 times a
second right I get to watch the texture
of my own mind be completely
unresponsive and useless I see every
single
um prideful decision every single lie
that I tell myself every single time I
make a promise and don't keep it I don't
get to see that from everyone so I'd
always presume because of this asymmetry
that everybody else had it sorted and I
didn't and it also made me think that
everybody else's opinion was this
perfectly balanced
well-researched beautifully it was it
was they had they had me nailed down to
a t what they were telling me was the
truth they could see something in me
that I couldn't right
and after a little bit of time and a
good bit of building up of
self-confidence I realized that that's
not the case no I have pity in a lot of
people
I do
um I used to get angry about it like
there was this guy I talked about it on
on Rogan this guy from still Team Six
who went out there when I became started
becoming more famous he went out there
and just tried to destroy me
try to literally destroy me talked about
how you know he's totally lied totally
lied had to get a lawyer against him all
kind of [ __ ]
and I was getting ready to Sue this guy
I had a great I was going to sue him
because he literally tried to destroy my
character my reputation went out there
in this lightest ass off
and I thought to myself
it's about two months into it I sat back
and I started feeling sorry for this guy
like really sorry for him I was gonna
pull the trigger assume and I said I'm
not gonna Sue this guy
I said for you to be
this person who comes on and lies and
tries to literally tear down
everything I've worked for
you are in a very very bad place come to
find out he was
in a very bad mental place so I get what
you're saying I've learned to study
people before I react
because there's no successful person in
the world who's in a good headspace
that's going to ever attack anyone in
that kind of manner there's always going
to be something wrong with them so you
got to always dive a little deeper
before you get your feelings hurt before
you get your feelings hurt by that bully
at school or that boss at work
take time take that one second to pull
back and study them
because most people were in good places
they don't they don't care about what
you're doing they don't care about what
you're doing they don't try to destroy
you they actually will try to build you
up versus destroy who you are as a
person so that's where I'm at now in
life is most people who do that doing a
very dark dark place this episode is
brought to you by element element is a
tasty electrolyte drink mix with
everything that you need and nothing
that you don't I've replaced my morning
coffee with element every day for over
three years now and I've never looked
back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to feel my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
wisdom thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that clip with Goggins
then press here for the full episode in
all of its glory and don't forget to
subscribe
[Music]